e na área da economia precisamente na
área financeira a gente viu um avanço
entre dez anos de você usar cheque
emissão de cartão de crédito lá em
plástico boleto e o QR Code que a gente
conhece agora mas o meu primeiro contato
com que acorde não foi do pics como
vocês conhecem foi através de uma
carteira de 30 moeda lá em meados de
2012 eu senti da hora que era o meu
futuro eu resolvi Largar uma carreira
promissora no grande banco e seguir para
criação e evolução de ser costela
e no início minha família levou um susto
na hora e por quê Porque ela eles falam
acostumada com o modelo tradicional de
emprego O que é viver em segurança numa
grande carreira um grande banco
E então naquela época momento pós-crise
2008 a crise que teve imobiliária lá nos
Estados Unidos um grande certeza novas
tecnologias novas ideias impossível é um
surgimento do iPhone na época eu pensei
comigo
O que será que eu consigo fazer um mês
de pagamento integrado com 14 anos
trabalhando na indústria bancária será
que as pessoas poderiam utilizar esse
meio de pagamento e será todo o proveito
que essa nova tecnologia tem
E aí a gente conseguiu fazer só que a
gente tem um problema à medida que o
tempo passava
é essa que sua mãe dela se valorizou
então cada vez que você faz uma
atualização é cobrado uma o valor pela
operação a gente chama de taxa de
mineração ou mais enfim só que para
pagar um cafezinho com pão uma padaria
que custa em média 10 12 reais você hoje
para você ter ideia se precisaria pagar
sem r$ 110 só de operação e para mim
essa operação se você fizesse um envio
de 1 milhão de reais os meus sem o 110
em média para você fazer a mesma
operação então o bloco tem um para essa
solução usando a geração um falhou
é só que a gente não parou por aí
Bom dia Geração 2 a geração dois ela foi
marcada por contratos inteligentes onde
era possível você fazer tokenização de
ativos e fazer a uma programação dos
pagamentos a princípio foi um sucesso só
que aí que acabou acontecendo o mesmo
problema ela era tão boa que a Crypton
moeda se valorizou e como a taxa é paga
na unidade que tô moeda o mesmo
cafezinho hoje para vocês terem uma
ideia custa como taxa de interação r$ 60
e a gente tem certeza que esse valor vai
aumentar e ao homem tá o que acaba
acontecendo é que realmente se torna
inviável e mais do que isso no momento
que começamos uma uma emissão de
localização uma missão de criação de
valores
se deparou para uma segunda questão que
é como é que pessoas comuns conseguir
utilizar e administrar Chaves fotografia
como é que fica segurança jurídica em
relação à
a sucessão herança disputa judicial
indenização então o modelo tradicional
que existia e que hoje é utilizado não
poderia atender pessoas comuns
é só que ao mesmo tempo
eu tava nascendo um novo sistema de
pagamento no Brasil que possui um dos
mais eficientes e seguros sistemas do
Mundo Chamado pics é o mesmo que é pôde
que me estimulou lá atrás em eu cheguei
a carreira ligada a a integração
bancária com essa tecnologia blockchain
só que o pics conseguiu de uma maneira
elegante conseguir fazer a gestão desses
acessos Então hoje você tem uma pessoa
comum que aponta o celular para uma
carteira de recebimento ou quando você
tá no caixa de um supermercado se a
ponta do celular e imediatamente você
tem só uma validação e toda a
complexidade
é do que teria que ser feito por trás
essa atualização fica por conta da
infraestrutura do pics então eu pensei
E se a gente fizesse isso também
é isso a gente aprendesse as lições e o
novo sistema de pagamentos que hoje
processa um trilhão de reais de maneira
brilhante mas ao mesmo tempo eu pudesse
ter acesso a outros ativos nessa
infra-estrutura nesses ativos que são
emitidos em blockchain para gente
conhecer um pouco mais sobre o termo da
nova economia ele foi Originalmente
citado lá em 83 pela revista Times e
esse jornalista o Charles Alexander ele
tava introduzindo como é que seria
colocar
e o consumidor como centro dessa relação
com a economia atual a gente viu essa
intensa transformação que seria uma
relação entre o consumidor as marcas
produtos e serviços com a Inovação EA
tecnologia e o futuro do bloco China
nova economia
é uma coisa é certa blocos em o futuro
E por que gerará várias oportunidades
novas profissões novas invenções novas
integrações novas experiências com
usuário
é E essas novas interações experiências
usuário veio para acrescentar
é muito mais o sucesso dessa
transformação social nessa era da nova
economia imagina comigo se por um lado
você tem em dez anos a evolução de
cheque que você assinava até que a cold
do PIS e do outro lado você tem mais dez
anos de bloco em que ele foi criado lá
em 2009
e já imaginou como seria os próximos
cinco anos onde a nova economia iria se
unir com esses dois universos
bom obrigado
E aí